On a renforcé le dispositif
qui permet de lutter contre les trafics.
Il y avait une question
simplement de répondre à une actualité.
C'est-à-dire que du jour au lendemain,
les douanes allaient perdre
leur pouvoir d'aller faire des contrôles.
Puisqu'il n'y avait pas eu de texte
qui concernait les douanes
depuis plus d'un demi siècle.
Ça a été aussi l'occasion,
de venir leur donner
les moyens de lutter contre la sophistication,
j'ai envie de dire grandissante
des trafics en tout genre.
Ce projet de loi a permis
beaucoup d'évolutions qui répondent
véritablement aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui.
Il faut que la loi soit en mesure
de mettre fin aux agissements des criminels qui, eux,
utilisent tous les artifices qu'ils ont
pour pouvoir faire leurs méfaits.
On voit aussi qu'il s'agit de sécuriser leurs actions.
Des amendements aussi ont été portés
par Christophe Blanchet et qui sont venus,
par exemple, faciliter la participation
à la réserve douanière
qui va être créée par ce texte.
La réserve opérationnelle,
qui permettra aux citoyens
qui veulent s'engager de pouvoir s'engager
aussi dans les douanes s'ils le souhaitent,
jusqu'à 30 jours par an.
Ou des retraités douaniers
de devenir réservistes pour, à un moment donné,
permettre aux douanes d'être
en force sur des actions ponctuelles.
Les douanes étaient la seule institution
qui n'avait pas de réserve.
On a aussi des dispositions qui renforcent
la lutte contre la contrefaçon
et notamment la vente en ligne,
pour là aussi sécuriser les dispositifs.
Donc, il fallait permettre aux douanes
de pouvoir s'adapter au monde réel d'aujourd'hui.
Ce projet de loi va véritablement
donner des moyens supplémentaires
et sans doute inspirer aussi d'autres juridictions
pour aller encore plus loin.
L'année dernière,
les douanes ont saisi 11,5 millions d'objets contrefaits
et deux tiers de ces objets
étaient des jeux et jouets pour enfants.
Il faut continuer
à donner les moyens aux douanes
pour protéger ne serait ce que un minimum nos enfants.
Concrètement, il n'y a pas de grande modification
pour les Français, par contre pour les malfrats,
pour les voyous, pour les trafiquants,
et bien oui, ça va changer
puisqu’on a renforcé le dispositif
qui permet de lutter contre les trafics.